one of my favorite holiday events is set
for this Saturday the 16th annual St
Jude's Ranch for children Night of
Lights and here to tell us more about it
we are joined by Dr Christina Vela the
CEO of St Jude's Ranch for children
thanks for being here of course happy
holidays it's so good to see you happy
holidays I love this event I want to
talk about that in a second but for
people who are for whatever reason not
familiar with Saint Jude's Ranch for
children tell them what you're about
yeah for over 56 years we have been
serving child victims of obesity neglect
homeless young people and our newest
project is to take care of child victims
of sex trafficking so for all of these
years our mission has been to provide
hope and healing to so many kids and
Families in Need and you've made such a
difference for more than half a century
now and it's just beautiful to see so
this event is all about celebration it
is it's all about celebrations the
holidays bringing our community together
and helping the kids that call Sanchez
Ranch for children their home to feel
really proud of having a community come
out and enjoy the holidays it's a chance
to get a taste of what goes on in the
spirit yeah Saint Jude's Ranch for
children which I really think is
palpable there's no admission right well
actually there is this year we're asking
people to make a 10 donation for all
inclusive wristbands okay that gives
them access to all of the and you know
there's Santa's workshop and cookies and
hot cocoa and popcorn all that's
included in the wristbands we're also
going to have food trucks now that
people can purchase separately yeah but
there's tons of games and cotton candy
and hot chocolate and all the things
that you know make it feel like a great
holiday event and of course lots of
lights and and a hayride I mean where
else can you get a hayride around our
beautiful campus right and rumor is
Santa's going to be there Santa and Mrs
Claus are going to make an appearance
and and be there for pictures that is
fantastic well congratulations to
everything you have going on have you
Broken Ground on the new center we did
we broke round a couple months ago and
we actually have a matching Grant right
now so for every dollar committed to The
Healing Center to care for child victims
of sex trafficking we have a two million
dollar matching Grant so if people want
to learn more about how to support child
victims of trafficking they can visit St
G's Ranch for no
stjudesranch.org our website to learn
more what's beautiful about that is I
remember talking to you a few years back
and this was a dream of yours you saw
this need there's such a problem that we
don't talk about a lot and it's so sad
that there are children still there are
so many that are victims of trafficking
and here is a solution yeah we are one
of you know one of few Solutions in our
community and we hope to continue to to
have more but yeah there's so many
children in need and sex trafficking is
something that is happening every day
and all of our children are really at
risk in one way or another and it's time
to provide those wrap around services
that they so much need for people who
haven't been out to the campus I want
them to understand what it is you have
Cottages where there are families there
are
couples that live there sometimes single
parents that live there with children
under their roofs yeah it's a foster
parent model so instead of being a
foster parent out in the community which
we can help people be that too but
people choose to come and be foster
parents on our campus we have 10 homes
it's a it's a beautiful sort of
Community of Hope and healing and
families yes husbands and wives can
become foster parents and with their own
biological children come into the home
with their pets and have a beautiful
blended family and caring for children
in need of foster care yeah and it works
it's beautiful to see all right so this
Saturday the big celebration the holiday
party 16th annual from 5 to 8 p.m and my
understanding is you have a tremendous
host we do have a tremendous time you
got the cream of the crop the best of
the best
who oh it's you Ted
yes
I'm happy to be I'm happy to host this
guys I'm really looking forward to it
thank you guys so much for this and of
course we have good weather for it right